au début de la trentaine Marx vit à
Londres il sait qu'il est surveillé par
des espions Prussiens un de ses espions
réussite à obtenir sa confiance en se
faisant passer pour un militant Marc sur
l'invite chez lui et voici ce que
l'espion écrira dans son rapport Marx
mène une vie de bohème rarement il se
lave et change de sous-vêtements il est
facilement sous il traîne souvent toute
la journée mais s'il a du travail il s'y
a donne jour et nuit il n'a pas
d'horaire pour dormir et se lever
souvent il reste debout toute la nuit et
la matinée puis se couche vers midi sur
un canapé tout habillé et dehors
jusqu'au soir sans tenir compte des
allées et venu autour de lui ce sont les
idées de cet homme qui ont changé le
monde au 20e siècle
[Musique]
vous connaissez peut-être cette citation
de Marx les philosophes n'ont fait
qu'interpréter le monde de diverses
manières ce qui importe c'est de le
transformer bon et bien il a suivi sa
propre recommandation aucun homme n'a
exercé sur le monde une influence
comparable à celle qui a eu Karl Marx au
XXe siècle et nous vivons encore sous
son influence c'est donc crucial pour
comprendre le monde de comprendre
comment les idées de Marx ont germé dans
son esprit comment un homme qui n'a
jamais mis le pied dans une usine et
devenu le prophète des ouvriers mais
vous allez voir que Marx n'est pas pour
autant un imposteur je vais vous
raconter 10 anecdotes étonnantes et
révélatrices sur sa vie c'est parti
les chiens ne font pas des chats dit
l'adage ce n'est pas toujours vrai mais
ça l'est pour Marx un de ces principaux
traits de personnalité c'est la
curiosité l'appétit intellectuelle il
s'intéresse à tous les champs du savoir
à tous les pays à toutes les époques
d'ailleurs la biographie que j'ai lu
pour faire cette vidéo s'intitule Karl
Marx ou l'esprit du monde et bien car le
tient son appétit intellectuel de son
père Heinrich Marx c'est avocat et
passionné de politique au point que
malgré la censure qui règne dans la
Prusse de l'époque il crée un club
intellectuel qui réunit la bourgeoisie
éclairée à Trèves il parle de
philosophie de littérature de politique
et des dernières innovations
scientifiques avec des négociants des
notables et même des profs de philo ils
évoquent aussi les premières communautés
socialistes créées au début du 19e
siècle et Heinrich cet homme d'une
grande curiosité intellectuelle à une
relation très forte avec son fils depuis
son plus jeune âge à l'adolescence car
elle a déjà des conversations profondes
avec son père il lui fait découvrir les
grands économistes de l'époque comme le
conte de Saint-Simon car le rencontre
aussi les membres du club intellectuel
de son père et bien sûr il s'enrichit à
leur contact ce que montre cette
anecdote c'est que le génie intellectuel
de Karl Marx est le fruit d'une
stimulation précoce à la vérité c'est la
même chose dans tous les domaines qu'il
s'agisse de musique de football ou de la
pensée l'excellence est très souvent le
résultat d'une stimulation précoce la
plupart du temps exercé par les parents
les sœurs de Marx se racontent qu'enfant
il les obligeait à dévaler une colline
alors qu'il était à cheval sur leur dos
il les forçait aussi à manger des
gâteaux dégoûtants qu'il avait lui-même
confectionné avec une pâte sale et elle
lui obéissait mais pourquoi est-ce
qu'elle lui obéissait parce qu'elle
voulait à tout prix qu'il leur raconte
des histoires elles disent qu'il avait
un incroyable talent de compteur au
point qu'elles en étaient dépendantes un
peu comme nous pouvons aujourd'hui être
dépendant de certaines séries sur
Netflix d'après ses sœurs Marx a une
personnalité exceptionnelle dès
l'enfance il rayonne il marque les gens
et il les attire à lui c'est ce qu'on
appelle le charisme ça sera également le
cas à l'université où son père l'envoi
étudier le droit quand il a 17 ans si
Marx n'est pas imposant physiquement il
est de taille et de corpulence moyenne
il cultive un style particulier il
soigne son abondance chevelure et se
laisse déjà pousser une petite barbe
mais surtout sa personnalité s'imprime
dans l'esprit de ses camarades parce
qu'il fait tout de façon extrême le
travail les nuits blanches les violences
verbales et physiques et l'alcool il
multip les soirées il se bat il achète
même un pistolet pour se protéger de ses
rivaux ce que montre cette anecdote
c'est que la diffusion des idées de Marx
est aussi le fruit de son charisme
personnel il rencontrera beaucoup
d'intellectuels tout au long de sa vie
et le magnétisme de sa personnalité de
sa confiance en lui le charisme avec
lequel il leur exposera ses thèses fera
beaucoup pour leur adoption et leur
diffusion et j'irai même plus loin Marx
n'est pas seulement un penseur
charismatique il y a aussi en lui un
leader charismatique un meneur d'homme
qui s'est imposé sa volonté depuis les
mauvais traitements qui fait subir à ses
soeurs en passant par les associations
universitaires il aime commander dans
tout ce qu'il entreprend cette qualité
lui permettra notamment de créer
l'organisation communiste internationale
un agent secret qui a infiltré
l'entourage de Marx note qu'il est
entouré de compagnons prêt à tout pour
le servir
à la fac de droit de bonne marque se
dépense sans compter tout l'argent que
lui envoie son père pire il contracte en
seulement quelques mois des dettes
considérables que son père remboursera
en protestant c'est comme ça que
commence la relation complexe de Marx
avec l'argent d'abord il ne cherche pas
à gagner beaucoup d'argent il considère
que c'est une forme d'esclavage il parle
d'aliénation dans sa théorie du coup il
sera pauvre l'essentiel de sa vie lui
elle lui fait pas grand chose mais il
culpabilise de laisser sa famille dans
la misère sa femme ses enfants et lui
doivent parfois s'entasser dans des
logements exiguës et insalubre à Londres
notamment il est soulagé lorsque des
rentrées d'argent leur permettent de
retrouver un minimum de confort même
malheureusement il se remette à vivre
au-dessus de ses moyens et à contracter
des dettes par exemple il emménage dans
une maison dans le loyer asséchera ses
finances en seulement quelques mois où
il paye des cours particuliers à ses
filles ses besoins financiers le
poussent à produire des articles et des
livres mais les revenus qui en tirent
sont négligeables par rapport à ses
besoins s'il s'en sort c'est grâce à des
héritages il celui de sa femme il y a
ensuite le sien au milieu de la
quarantaine il sort durablement de la
misère en touchant une grosse part de
l'héritage de ses parents et enfin il y
a surtout tout l'argent que lui envoie
son meilleur ami Engels c'est grâce à
lui que la famille de Marx se survit
dans la misère Friedrich Engels c'est le
co-auteur du fameux mammifeste du Parti
communiste fils d'un industriel qui a
fait fortune dans le textile angel se
finance son ami parce qu'il est
convaincu que Marx a un grand destin que
ses idées vont changer le monde
certaines années il contribuent à
hauteur des deux tiers au revenu de la
famille un jour Marx n'a même pas assez
d'argent pour envoyer le manuscrit de sa
contribution à la critique de l'économie
politique à l'éditeur donc il envoie une
énième lettre à Engels pour lui demander
de l'argent il lui écrit cette phrase
qui deviendra célèbre je ne pense pas
qu'on n'est jamais écrit sur l'argent
tout en en manquant à ce point cette
anecdote est révélatrice à plusieurs
égards mais le plus intéressant à mes
yeux c'est qu'il nous fait penser que
c'est le rapport personnel de Marx à
l'argent qui explique sa théorie
économique travailler pour gagner de
l'argent c'est un esclavage auquel
marque CE ne veut pas se soumettre
souvenez à ses besoins grâce à des
héritages ça ne fait pas très prolétaire
mais ce n'est pas la seule chose qui ne
fait pas prolétère chez Marx à 25 ans
Karl Marx épouse Jenny phone veste
fallen et le mot allemand fun ça
signifie de en français autrement dit
marc se marie avec une aristocrate la
famille de Jenny fait même partie de
l'élite prussienne ça non plus ça ne
fait pas très prolétaire les biographes
s'interrogeront sur ce mariage certains
verront dans l'attirance de Marx pour
une aristocrate un désir de s'affranchir
du travail mais la raison est bien plus
simple Jenny était sa voisine enfant il
jouait ensemble et ils ont continué de
se fréquenter à l'adolescence une fois
mariée elle deviendra sa collaboratrice
comme elle est elle aussi une
intellectuelle Marx lui parle de ses
lectures et de ses idées elle devient sa
première lectrice et restera la seule
capable de déchiffrer parfaitement son
écriture il lui fait même recopier ses
textes avant de les envoyer chez
l'imprimeur cette anecdote montre que le
prolétariat n'est pas le milieu social
de Marx certes il aime sincèrement sa
femme mais par elle il se déconnecte de
la partie de la population qu'il prétend
défendre d'ailleurs leur mariage n'était
pas placé sous le signe de la Révolution
ils ont dépensé sans compter lors de
leur lune de miel qu'ils ont passé sur
les chutes du Rhin
est une rue du quartier de Sceaux au
centre de Londres aujourd'hui c'est un
des quartiers les plus animés de la
capitale mais à l'époque c'était un des
plus mal famés un des biographes de la
femme de Marx à surnommé Jean Street la
rue de la mort en effet les conditions
de vie des marques se sont si misérables
que leurs enfants tombent malades les
uns après les autres ils perdent d'abord
leur deuxième fils Henry il succombe à
une pneumonie à moins d'un an la misère
est si grande le froid si vif que 18
mois plus tard les marques se perdent
leur fille Francesca c'est un voisin un
Français généreux qui paye pour le
cercueil enfin il perd de ton corps leur
premier fils Edgar qui meurt de la
tuberculose à 8 ans Marx s'est effondré
parce que c'était son fils préféré il
avait beaucoup investi dans leur
relation il avait commencé à initier son
fils à la culture classique au grec au
latin et aux langues étrangères il dira
que c'est dans cette rue Jean Street que
sa vie s'est brisée à partir du moment
où Marx se connaît la misère la maladie
et la mort ne le laisseront plus
tranquille il a déjà perdu trois enfants
donc il redouble de soins à l'égarder
trois filles qui lui restent mais la
maladie continuera avec la mort de
plusieurs petits enfants la maladie
s'attaque ensuite à lui alors qu'il
avait joui jusque là d'une solide
constitution il tombe sérieusement
malade pour la première fois après la
mort de sa fille Francesca il connaît
des crises de furoncle de foi les rages
de dents les infections oculaires puis
pulmonaires se multiplient il se remet
mais la maladie reviendra le terrasser à
intervalles réguliers elle l'empêchera
parfois de travailler pendant plusieurs
mois à la fin de sa vie sa santé est si
dégradée qu'il multiplie les séjours
dans des établissements de cure où il
constate que les gens le reconnaissent
ce que montre cette anecdote c'est que
Marx n'a pas travaillé pour son confort
personnel il a énormément souffert pour
produire et diffuser ses idées on peut
presque dire qu'il sait sacrifié pour
elle qu'il est un martyr une de ses
expressions favorites était d'ailleurs
travaillé pour l'humanité
la pauvreté la maladie et la mort c'est
déjà bien lourd à porter mais le fardeau
de Marx est encore plus lourd et bien
oui parce qu'en prêchant la révolution
on ne se fait pas des amis journalistes
dissident il est censuré et expulsé de
villes en ville il doit quitter Cologne
et l'Allemagne au milieu de la vingtaine
il passe deux ans à Paris jusqu'à être
expulsé il vit ensuite trois ans en
Belgique jusqu'à connaître encore le
même sort il repasse en France et en
Allemagne avant de s'installer à Londres
où il pourra rester jusqu'à sa mort Marx
représente une menace pour les États et
leurs services parce qu'il a noué des
liens avec tout un réseau européen
d'agitateurs socialistes donc toutes les
polices européennes le surveillent et
l'empêche de voyager elle place des
agents dans son entourage et bien sûr
elles sont sur les articles et les
ouvrages qui leur déplaisent elle
recourent aussi à ce qu'on appelle la
caractère assassination le fait de
diffamer intentionnellement une personne
afin de détruire la confiance du public
en cette personne en pratique elle
répand de diverses rumeurs marque s'est
accusé de mépriser le prolétariat
d'admirer l'aristocratie de diriger une
société secrète
saisir toutes sortes de complots
abracades à brantesques ou encore de
détourner des fonds pour mener une vie
bourgeoise il y a même des accusations
précises il fabriquerait de la fausse
monnaie il ferait du chantage auprès
d'anciens communistes pour leur
extorquer de l'argent il serait même un
agent prussien un filtré dans les
milieux révolutionnaires au début Marx
le prend mal il provoque en duel trois
hommes qui ont répondu ce genre de Rago
et les trois font un abandonnables mais
avec le temps il s'habitue et laisse
dire cette anecdote montre que Marx est
un véritable ennemi du pouvoir ces idées
et son activité politique dérangent
elles sont perçues comme une véritable
menace
la sagesse populaire dit que la
personnalité du père détermine ce que sa
fille recherchera chez un homme et bien
la famille Marx se confirme vraiment
cette idée les trois filles tombent
amoureuses de socialistes de premier
plan la première à Jenny épouse Charles
Longuet qui s'était fait un nom lors de
la Commune de Paris cette insurrection
avait eu un retentissement international
la deuxième Laura avait épousé quatre
ans plus tôt Paul Lafargue qui était lui
aussi un intellectuel socialiste et qui
est l'auteur du fameux droit à la
paresse la troisième se fit en sa
prospère Olivier lisagare l'auteur du
témoignage de référence sur la Commune
de Paris puis elle fréquente Edward
havling un socialiste influent en
Angleterre au-delà de l’interprétation
psychologique cette anecdote montre que
Marx et sa famille évoluent dans un
milieu essentiellement composé de
socialistes et les affinités politiques
deviennent des affinités romantiques
puis familiales
les trois filles dont je viens de vous
parler sont les derniers enfants du
couple Marx ils ont eu sept enfants et
ils ont malheureusement perdu quatre en
bas âge tous à Londres mais voilà ça
c'est le décompte officiel à la fin 1850
la gouvernante des marques Hélène des
mute tombe enceinte en même temps que
Jenny la femme de Marx la cohabitation
entre les deux femmes enceintes n'est
pas facile dans le minuscule appartement
de Londres la domestique refuse d'avouer
le nom du père mais étant donné qu'elle
travaille à plein temps pour les Marx il
n'y a pas 50 possibilités pas dupe Jenny
la femme de Marx fait une dépression et
les rumeurs vont bon train pour les
faire taire Engels qui est un homme à
femme reconnaît l'enfant mais jamais ni
lui ni Marx ne s'en occuperont
l'orphelin deviendra ouvrier et militant
socialiste les trois filles de Marx se
considèreront ce fils caché comme leur
demi-frère mais lui ne sera rien de son
origine
arnoldruge et l'associé du jeu de Marx
voici ce qu'il écrit sur sa méthode de
travail il lit beaucoup il travaille
d'une manière extraordinairement
intensive il a un talent critique et qui
dégénère parfois en un pur jeu
dialectique mais il n'achève rien il
interrompt chaque recherche pour ce
plonger dans un nouvel océan de livre
c'est le problème de marque il ne sait
pas fini ce qu'il commence en fait il
est perfectionniste il n'est jamais
satisfait de son travail il veut
toujours apporter des modifications il
trouve toujours qu'il peut mieux
exprimer ses idées sa désespère ses
proches et la pression d'un éditeur n'y
fait rien par exemple à la fin de la
vingtaine Marx signe un contrat avec un
éditeur pour publier une histoire
critique de l'économie politique comme
il s'engage à donner le manuscrit six
mois plus tard il touche un premier
acompte mais il ne remettra jamais le
manuscrit et il ne remboursera jamais
l'éditeur et c'est toujours comme ça au
début de l'année 1858 par exemple Marx a
déjà écrit près de 800 pages dans
lesquelles il expose l'essentiel de sa
théorie économique il a énormément
travaillé les mois précédents 800 pages
n'est pas l'histoire d'une demi-heure le
manuscrit est prêt mais Marx tombe
malade il n'a plus la force de
travailler pendant trois mois certains
biographes lient ce trait de caractère
au concept d'aliénation Marc serait peur
en mettant un point final à un manuscrit
de se laisser raracher son œuvre comme
l'ouvrier qui est séparé du produit de
son travail
Marx lit l'origine des espèces le
chef-d'œuvre de Darwin au début de la
quarantaine et il note je suis surpris
de voir Darwin redécouvrir chez les
bêtes et les plantes les caractères de
la société anglaise avec sa division du
travail sa concurrence l'ouverture des
marchés l'innovation et la lutte pour la
vie Engels et Marc pensent que Darwin a
la même vision du monde que qu'il est
dès lors et ça tombe bien Darwin
n'habite qui a une trentaine de
kilomètres de Marx mais voilà
l'admiration n'est pas réciproque au
début de la cinquantaine Marx fait
envoyer une réédition du premier tome du
capital à Darwin il le lui dédicace en
précisant qu'il est son sincère
admirateur Darwin le remercie poliment
mais il s'excuse de ne pas avoir les
compétences requises pour le lire il ne
remarque donc pas que Marx le mentionne
à trois reprises dans le livre et selon
certaines sources lorsque paraîtra la
version anglaise du Capital Marx écrira
à Darwin pour lui proposer de la lui
dédiée mais Darwin déclinera cette
honneur
voilà voilà j'espère que cette vidéo
vous a plu que vous avez découvert des
choses intéressantes et même inspirantes
sur Marx si c'est le cas donnez un pouce
bleu à la vidéo et puis laissez un
commentaire afin d'améliorer le
référencement de la vidéo ce n'est pas
grand chose et ça m'aide vraiment je
suis romain j'étais avec mon fidèle
Aristote et vous vous étiez sur 1000
idées de culture générale rappelez-vous
que vous n'avez pas besoin de vous
prendre la tête pour vous intéresser aux
meilleurs de la pensée j'ai une question
à vous poser vous croyez vraiment que
les gens ont lu tous les livres dont il
parle bien sûr que non sinon on ne
pourrait pas parler de grand chose
et oui il y a 24 heures dans une journée
et il faut travailler manger dormir et
sortir le chien
[Musique]
donc le secret de la culture générale ce
n'est pas de lire des livres c'est quoi
alors et bien en fait il n'y a pas un
seul secret il y en a 5 les étudiants et
les personnes les plus cultivées les
profs et les intellectuels connaissent
ces cinq secrets savez vous avez dû
Renan comme moi mais il se garde bien
d'en parler les gens qui les découvrent
réussissent à développer rapidement et
facilement leur culture générale parce
que leur rapport au savoir a changé et
une fois qu'il les applique les cinq
secrets ils comprennent toutes les
références des personnes cultivées ils
savent s'exprimer avec profondeur sur
n'importe quel sujet il brille par leur
culture dans les conversations et dans
les débats et ils ont le recul
nécessaire pour faire preuve d'esprit
critique ça vous intéresse et bien je
vous révèle les cinq secrets et je vous
explique comment les appliquer dès
aujourd'hui pour vous cultiver dix fois
plus rapidement sans vous prendre la
tête pour recevoir les cinq secrets
inscrivez-vous simplement soit en
cliquant sur le lien qui apparaît
maintenant en haut à droite de la vidéo
soit tranquille sur celui qui est dans
la description de cette vidéo croyez-moi
faites-le et vous me remercierez